uh you know i'm very pleased today
because we have a visitor connor from
language tsar hi everybody
um
how do you go about learning these
languages ah okay
so
first i start i need to first identify
my motivation right because i think
that's one thing that a lot of people
who struggle languages and i know you've
discussed it on your channel so so much
which has always been a great
inspiration to watch these uh videos so
if you're watching his channel for the
first time go there's like how many 800
or something insane
yeah it's an amazing resource for
everybody so the first thing that
invites your motivation because okay you
might wake up when you say it'd be great
to speak chinese right and you'll be
really motivated because it's all new
but if you don't have a good long-term
motivation it's very hard over like
months and then years to continue with
the language right so i'll give you an
example
last year i started learning irish right
because i was actually born in ireland
even though i don't speak the language
and i was super excited motivated for
the first three months right because i
was learning the language i heard it at
school in my my childhood
and then after the three months i didn't
have any friends who spoke it uh okay i
watched a little bit of television but
there wasn't really that urgency there
wasn't really that very clear
reason for me to learn it right when am
i going to use it in the future and then
it's very hard to keep
you know sacrificed learning another
language or doing something else as
opposed to learning irish so that's the
first thing i'm trying to identify so
ukrainian it's pretty simple i'm going
to go to live i like to spend a lot of
time in the country even if i'm in a
russian speaking a predominantly
russian-speaking city like odessa
they're always going to be opportunities
to use ukrainians so i know exactly why
i'm learning it right right uh and then
i would i have i already speak a cognate
language which is russian so then i know
i'm going to understand a certain amount
of vocabulary and in this case probably
a lot of the grammatical structures so
i'm going to first just start listening
to the language a lot right
and then if i have the opportunity but
ukraine has come easy because i'm going
to go to the country and then use it i
may also buy a course i'm not going to
try out linked of course
that we've been discussing a little bit
of strategy together today me and steve
and then like there's certain other
products i'm going to try out like i'm
going to try
glossika i'm going to try out uh vodka
booster and i'm going to write this all
on the blog as well on language stars if
you're interested you can go there and
you can see my reports and also on my
youtube channel and then after that i
try to build up real genuine
relationships with the people and
consume the media
learn about the culture because these
are all things where you can by osmosis
absorb a lot of the grammar the
vocabulary have motivation to use it uh
that comes kind of externally to the
study right right and then i will have a
tutor that i found via italki uh which
is another great place marketplace for
finding teachers and we'll have probably
one or two classes i don't like to have
more than two hours a week because i
think people who start off with five for
the three weeks you have to make huge
progress it's very impressive but
they're not going to do that for six
months a year because you're just going
to burn out or you don't have that
urgency so i prefer to start with two if
it goes down to one it's not such a big
drop and then consistently to learn the
language and use it over several years i
don't see it as a three-month project to
learn ukrainian and then abandon it
right afterwards i see the language
learning is a lifelong process and some
languages like they just don't work out
they didn't you know either i wasn't
motivated enough and that's fine you
leave them one side and you say okay now
i focus on another one because you
always have this trade-off so that's
normally how i approach learning
languages uh when it's a new one you
know i i agree like i first of all
italki is a great place to find tutors
you can try out several tutors and then
settle on the one that you like the best
and uh twice a week is ample
because there's so much else involved
like you need to improve for that next
session with with the tutor because
you're not going to be you're not going
to improve just by
totally just speaking with a tutor you
have to do your listening and connecting
with the culture and and so forth and
then you go back to your tutor and twice
a week is a good number and and one that
you can maintain well that's the game so
long-term exactly so no i i totally
agree with you the motivation part uh
connecting with the culture that's
exactly how i go about it
and long-term absolutely like if you
learn the language in two weeks i made a
video on this or nisto has a tweet on
twitter if you learn it fast you're
going to forget it fast yeah that
doesn't make sense to me
and if you enjoy the language like i've
you mentioned ukrainian i enjoy it like
every day i get my my podcast from
promozca and i just
it's fascinating to hear them and all
the things that they're preoccupied with
and as you're you're interested in the
subject then you're also picking up the
language yeah and particularly with
listening the only thing i would say is
particularly in the early stages
whatever i listen to i got to read
because if i just listen to it it just
takes that much longer to pick up on it
because there's so many words there that
you aren't going to recognize whereas if
you had the opportunity to read it and
look it up and of course the way we do
it link you're looking it up and then
you're reviewing the words you're
actually you know deliberately mining
this material for words and phrases so
that after a while there's fewer and
fewer words that you don't understand
and and when i don't understand it's
mostly because i don't have the words
it's not because the grammar was so
confusing that i couldn't understand the
accent for example
it's it's mostly once you get past the
stage where you know initially you can't
even tell words where words end and
begin but once you get past that stage
and you're hearing this word but you
don't know what the word is it's your
lack of knowledge of the word so
you know i think i like to have a
deliberate strategy of increasing my
vocabulary and i found as i said in one
of my recent videos when i get past and
it may sound stupid like 40 000 words
but in a slavic language there's a lot
of you know inflections but once you get
to that 40 000 words stage
uh you understand just about every 40
thousand words 40 000. but you get there
very quickly i got in polish i'm at 30
000 and i don't understand my polish as
well as my ukrainian okay
it's just it's just a number i find and
my koreans at 20 000 have even more
trouble understanding it so because
you're picking most of these words up
like for free
incidentally because you don't need to
save them you'll find in ukrainian once
you get a sense of how that language
although in fact the vocabulary is
closer to polars than it is today
but you're going to start all these
words you're just going to be adding
words like crazy you'll be up to ten
thousand words in no time all right just
gotta keep on working at it well we'll
have to i'll have to post the video
later on okay show you my progression
right how many words exactly i get up to
right so but that's also part of
motivation because just to stretch
this point here that there are times
when you feel you're not making progress
yeah so at least to be aware that your
word count is growing and that there is
a magic point at which all of a sudden
the stuff a lot of which
seems so difficult always to get to
understand it's going to click in so
that's important to maintain that
motivation because once you get past
that initial period where wow i can say
something in the language i actually
understand something in the language to
get from there to genuine fluency is a
long road exactly the last i always find
that the last five percent takes maybe
as long as the first 95 percent in the
language and that's something that
everybody has to calculate is going that
extra five percent worth it with your
own goals it's not me exactly
everyone yeah exactly okay steve yes
very interesting we could probably go on
forever i think we can make a two-hour
documentary
yeah exactly we can make another video
about that in the future okay okay well
thanks for having me on the the channel
i'm a great i'm a big fan and you've
always been a great integration so
looking forward to the following
languages
okay
bye
you